we are
marilyn jo hannah from rose common berry
farm
we are located in brutal dallas county
outside of linden iowa we
grow strawberries and raspberries
currently
and are looking at expanding into other
berries for future years
we grow our strawberries in a somewhat
unique
situation they're day neutral
strawberries so we treat them as an
annual and
plant new ones every spring for harvest
somewhere between first harvest starts
from july 1st to july
20th depending on the year a little bit
but what really makes our
strawberry system unique is that we grow
them in
vertical upright hydroponic tower so
there's
no bending over and picking off the
ground everything is done from
knee high to head height this is our
second year of
production on the farm last year was
just kind of getting things
up and going and getting a lot of
infrastructure
built we had some definitely major
challenges
last year which the sierra grant is
actually helping us figure out
this year we have about nine acres
across the whole
farm that we own and right now we just
have crops in
basically about three quarters to one
acre
the strawberries that we have we had
about 17
000 out there when we started this
spring again but that's
all in you know a half acre size
we have three weeks of rain literally
every single day so you'll find a few
empty potholes and things out there but
that's a really good
comparison of what works well under
flooding and drought conditions because
we've had
flood condition well not flood last year
but we had
a lot of rain last year during the
growing season we had constant
preliminary trials set up
we've had basically now at this point
three weeks up until today when we
record it
of bone dry weather um and so i think
we're growing
we're going to learn a lot of good
information from the trial this year
and we already have we've started
collecting some of our data
and can easily see a difference between
certain
of our trials of our different media as
far as
different take rates so we're seeing
some
plant size plant health and labor that's
involved
how can we mechanize some of this and
we'll talk about all that as we go
through the individual
pots we have 15 rows of our towers out
here
we have 10 rows that are 60 towers each
roughly give or take and then five that
are 40
in our smaller field and in each of the
towers so each of the 60 or 40 there are
five of these cloverleaf
pots that just stack snap
together and so each pot
holds four plants so then for each tower
it's 20
obviously multiplied out for the field
itself
in our trial we have four different
media types
that are in the middle of our field our
big field
so we can see side-by-side comparisons
of what they look like compared to each
other
the field that you see behind us it's
basically we had to put together a
trellis
to hold the pots up they're all um it's
half inch conduit with uh inch and a
half
inch and a quarter or something like
that pvc that holds the tower
or the pots up off the ground at knee
height there
um because we're on a windy location we
had to go through
and add some end posts and some ground
stakes and a couple eight foot t-post
staggered throughout
with a high tensile wire there's not
really any tension on that wire but just
something to hold those conduit from
moving
around you'll notice that our rows are
north and south here it the property
actually doesn't quite
look like it is north and south the way
we're sitting here but it actually is
sitting fairly close to north-south
and the reason that they're set there
are set up like that way is so that the
morning sun can come
up and trans and move over and actually
catch
basically three sides of the towers over
the course of the day in order
to get uniform growth in uniform
ripening
it is a management type thing that we
have to do though is go through and
rotate
those pots uh 180 degrees once a day
we do that for sunlight we do that to
give the plants a little bit of a break
from the wind
and irrigation and irrigation water flow
distribution
through the towers this is our first
trial
um this is a mix of the
chips that we saw hydrating before that
was in the bag
not ground up though it's just the chips
and then it's a mix
of the peat material that we saw
hydrated
and it's mixed at one part p three parts
chips
i believe um so the peat holds the water
the cheap
chips give us drainage the chips
actually
ebb and flow a little bit of nutrients i
think as well i can't
100 verify that so pros to this media is
it's
fairly well drained and you can easily
change drainage by adding
more peat to that mix to suit your needs
right now we're finding about similar
water usage across the board from all
our media
out here i don't know that that will
hold through as plants start to
size up though the next treatment here
is the peat that we
had so the ground up peat mixed up with
the chips that we have
but the chips are also ran through the
chipper shredder
thing um i think we're at one part pete
and three parts of uh ground up chips
out here the chips themselves are pretty
well
drained and get pretty dry and there
that one is a great option
for wet years so we wanted to see if we
could find
that same material and make it to be a
little bit more suitable for
a wet year yeah you end up with a ton of
labor
i mean because you're already running
stuff for the chipper then you gotta
back
mix it with the peat and it doesn't
store well so it's not something we can
do during the off season
i've got iron chlorosis on
some of these some of these leaves so i
still need to fold fully refeed it and
things like that and account for some of
the
excess of bleaching that the other media
has so i'm not gaining anything
by adding the extra labor to this media
so this one will never be seen on this
farm again
another media that's in this trial this
one is the
chips that we had and then ran through
the chipper shredder mulcher
thing and it's just a nice fine grain
material that we saw
earlier the reason that we like this one
is it's very well drained
so we get into a wet year water moves
down through here and these strawberries
are never wet
in fact we got a half inch of rain this
morning we may
if it gets sunny and warm out we may
have to irrigate this afternoon
and i should mention all of these are on
a twice a day irrigation cycle that's
the way we're set up
the challenges on it though is the
nutrients run out
and then you end up with iron deficiency
so you can see i've got
some iron deficiency here so it becomes
really critical to make sure that you're
managing putting just enough water on to
get everything hydrated but not too much
and leaching excess out
and then coming back in you're going to
have to do some foliar feeding after
rain falls labor-wise the stuff is
really easy to
hydrate it's really easy to tip
other than it takes time right time is
the worst part of the labor with this
it's planting into it is really easy
it really doesn't take much time at all
it's so fine that you can just
pop plant right in really it's
the time that it takes to hydrate and
run everything through the
wood chipper finally we have our peat
and perlite mix this is again more
closer to what's generally used for
hydroponic strawberries and flat
culture beds
this is nice because you can pre-mix it
and put it all together and run it
through an auger
or a pot filler i mean this is designed
to go through a pot filler
it's also the cheapest overall of all
the different types of media
and the lowest labor of all the
different types of media
going to a what i think is a little bit
higher quality
p media going to a higher ratio
of perlite in there and perlite is going
to
[Music]
detract water so it's going to shed
water away from the plants
it's actually working out pretty well
for us the challenge on it
is it dries out and so when it dries out
it blows
and so we have peat and perlite that's
flown all over the place out of here
it's hard to keep it
wet on a windy windy day inside a
greenhouse or a high tunnel where we
could provide wind protection this would
be great
because it would never blow around it'd
be pretty easy to
manage and keep in place water flow and
distribution across these
it's a pots throughout the tower by far
this is the best
[Music]
again it's going to be your better
option when you get into a droughty
situation like we've had last couple
weeks we get into a wet period
we may end up struggling again so we'll
have to see how that goes
the other thing that i like about this
is that you can direct seed and plant
other things into it pretty easily
one other thing to note with the peat
and perlite
is i had commented on the ease in
planting into the chipped up stuff
this is even easier i think i had timed
at one point
and we were able to plant an entire
tower in a minute which means on a long
road you got an
hour planting which is fast i mean you
can do a short row like this
one person in 45 minutes right and our
reports will all reflect actual
person hours per per unit
but it's fast so what led us to the sare
farmer rancher program
[Music]
one of the challenges with growing
strawberries in these vertical upright
towers is um
water distribution water holding
capacity in these towers
oftentimes you will see the bottom
pots of these towers get too much water
and uh they go um
the start showing signs of iron
chlorosis boron deficiency
and it's very difficult to manage water
distribution and nutrient distribution
through those vertical
towers looking at the sare
projects looking at a lot of the other
research nobody's really doing a lot of
research on these vertical
towers they're all flat dead based
systems whether it's
farmer ranchers or whether it's
university research
we had a very specific question that we
wanted to
answer very specific to our farm but
it's
applicable to people that are growing
vertical strawberries across
across the country um and then
knowing krista um poking around and
asking some questions about how we go
about
go about doing this whether we can make
it work for us that's kind of what drove
us to
actually taking a chance to write
a project for the sare farmer rancher
grant here in the north central
region how easy or how difficult that is
i'm a little bit biased because i write
grants on a fairly regular
basis but again we knew what problem
that we
wanted to address and we were able to
sit down
and go through that process for the sare
farmer rancher grant
i think we started writing it and we set
it aside for about six months at
one point because we knew we were going
to apply but it wasn't around
but i spent a few hours one night kind
of throwing ideas together and starting
to figure out what our plots are going
to look like
and then when we came back to actually
write it and finish putting it together
it was not difficult one of the more
challenging
parts of the proposal although i found
it to be really valuable was to go back
and look at what the other sarah folks
had been doing in other regions we found
a lot of good information that was being
done
in other places and we were able to talk
about what else is being done
and how or why it's not relevant to us
but we did find some tips and tricks and
some information that we pulled
from those and we'll actually be able to
show some of the stuff that we pulled
uh not part of this part particular
project but stuff that we pulled
from another project that we're do that
we're trying out on our own farm